l tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
nuovo io sono fatti sembra il messia
ogni volta che faccio così io sono la vj
oggi siamo in un nuovo blog questa
settimana siamo con un blog molto ma
molto speciale perché allora la
settimana scorsa sono andato ad ibiza il
fine settimana è come vi avevo promesso
nello scorso blog ho fatto un pò fatto
un blog quindi de vico il blog
praticamente soltanto a questa cosa qui
in più c'è stata è successa una cosa nel
frattempo è successo ragazzi che nello
scorso vlog quello che ho fatto sabato
scorso quando ho messo la maglia addio a
specchio aprendo porte ragazzi ho messo
questa maglietta qui di oviesse poi
abbiamo fatto tipo loves ecco quando ho
fatto questa cosa qua e diventerà ora o
vs ma veramente visto il video ho
sputato sono messi d'accordo
e mi ha chiesto di fare un qualcosa di
partner izzato con loro su questo video
qui quindi è assurdo che vi abbiano
chiamato davvero perché io sono molto
sexy c'è il modello perfetto e quindi
ragazzi alla fine del video vi fingerò
uno di quelli che ti dice le promozioni
che ci sono parlando al telefono facendo
finta di essere in un call center con
delle persone che conosco e lo faccio
dopo questo alla fine del video
per il resto vi lascio al video di ibiza
quindi ragazzi spero che vi piaccia è
stato un grandissimo trip cielo rifare
tutta la vita anche se ho avuto la
febbre purtroppo nella sono goduta metà
però è stato veramente figo ragazzi
quindi spero che vi piaccia
vi lascio al video pesca perché sono il
ghiaccio non solo una iero 3 e ma lui
c'è quella più una scusa
come mai questo per tutto ibiza a fare
video 1 con un ago pro e uno con
un'altra bellissima sajad e vitale
costume da bagno
ci siamo siamo in due cose aveva fatto
un regalo ma resto qui di regalo grazie
all'aereo
ma quella di ma la camicetta
andate tutti affanculo
[Musica]
sì
per cariati siamo arrivati a ibiza e
stato un viaggio movimentato perché mi
veniva da vomitare sul passeggero che di
fianco che era una povera vecchia
questa è la piscina di casa mia proprio
questa qua prima st davies ma il caso
mai siete 6 bizze
[Musica]
no perché congiu ragazzi siamo al
secondo giorno ad ibiza rega e alla fede
credo che vi sia praticamente passata
quindi oggi per potermi godere la
giornata almeno abbiamo una pazza una
pazza una borsa anche grossa ovviamente
adesso io la ruberò tipo in gta no no
non tarda ma dopo ammazzo
di ricci coraggio e l'onesta
famiglia è già bello che in acqua
terreno che fa snorky sembri un coniglio
ce la puoi fare
parigi gela per fare
cazzo
qua
ammettiamo difficoltà
matera pompa come come sarà questa
ventata ragazzi siamo sulla barca da
stamattina si è fatto ma invece le gambe
davvero
che so non sono io sto preparando ma
sono né tipo l'una di notte che
praticamente a ibiza e mattina tutto il
mondo e mattino all'una di notte
effettivamente e prima di andare a
mettere del dentifricio
non so cosa no va beh non glielo faccia
scherzi e intrigato io chiudo qui il
video ci vediamo domani quando partiamo
con l'aereo e non è al top al suo
secondo dai privati che ne fa tanti
prendermi all'inizio è pronto anche il
giorno ragazzi era che se due pomeriggi
allegato seduto il pomeriggio e ceo di
vidyo è quindi ragazzi questo è stato il
mio viaggio ad ibiza v vi chiedo scusa
se non è lungo il video come quelle di
los angeles però siano stati solo due
giorni ragazzi non riuscivo a fare un
video enorme poi tra l'altro avevo anche
la febbre tra il cazzo di culo a parte
la febbre è stata la cosa più [ __ ] della
terra perché a me piace un sacco di
villa cioè io sognavo di andarci da da
ieri c'è un sacco di tempo che i ragazzi
allora passiamo al non faccia scattare i
pacchi fa vi risponde perché no
veramente un blog chilometrico faccio
questa specie di plan che mi avevano
chiesto di fare quelli di ovs e grazie
al video scorso dove hanno visto che ho
messo la maglietta dire che possiamo
partire con il brand che se riesco a
farlo perché non ho mai fatto una cosa
del genere
ho messo anche questo rumore di
sottofondo che sembra tipo ufficio
così sembra un po più real non lo so ci
provo lo stesso con che adesso chiamo e
si pronto salve volevamo solo annunciate
da oviesse ormai è ufficiale designer di
expo 2015 e oltre aver realizzato capi a
marco expo continuerà a lanciarne di
nuovi per tutta la durata
dell'esposizione collaborando coi
designer e di giovani talenti inoltre
abbiamo anche come nuovo testimonial fa
vj e
[Musica]
la scena viene 10 secondi ma ha dovuto
provare se ci riprovo si pronto salve
sono marco campagna cerba di oviesse
volevamo notificarle che stiamo aprendo
un nuovo digital su ping experience che
ancora più innovativa perché nella magic
sfitti room di oviesse può specchiarsi
scattarsi dei sensi e ricevere consigli
su proprio look
inoltre abbiamo anche al nuovo
testimonial di oviesse che fa vj per i
suoi figli si è interessata attraverso
telefono se magari lei e non lo stato è
stato fazione tempio se alle le piatte
non lo so i suoi figli fa vj abbiamo
tutta la collezione nuova perché lui è
il nuovo testimonial e quindi magari lei
una ragazza mi scusi l'avevo scambiata
per il mio amico maicol
comunque volevo dire abbiamo aperto un
nuovo centro di 3mila metri quadri a
milano il nostro flagship store più
grande in corso buenos aires
ringrazio moltissimo che è veramente
sentire lo sa che veramente gentile ma
vai a cagare tutti in macchina siete
oggi consta in macchina il povero marco
marco campagna cerva di oviesse come
anche chiamare tuffare che sono tutti in
macchina
ce ne fosse stato uno ma uno che ha
detto io lo conosco fa vj coin germi
amico no nessuno proprio l'ala della
serie ma chi cazzo lo conosce quindi
ragazzi
esso è stato tutto il progresso di pizza
di oviesse tutto quello che è successo
in questa settimana ha concluso episodio
ragazzi spero che vi sia piaciuto è come
al solito prima di concludere faccio la
fai domanda è la fai domanda è come
adesso ho fatto los angeles e ibiza come
blog
sono stati epici secondo me quale
dovrebbe essere il prossimo provato a
dirmelo ragazzi e provare a fare un blog
in quel luogo mi sveglierò la mattina
tipo in giappone che bello già podio di
andare in giappone prima di concludere
ragazzi vi lascia uno spezzone finale
che merita tutta la vostra attenzione ed
è molto importante
marco campagna in live
o sue mani appena tentati di mihai ha
fiato da fuoco davanti a zero e gli
occhi pieni di feriti
la tua campagna nel 2015 grazie
e a femminile quindi ragazzi spero che
vi sia piaciuto e cosa sento seguito è
piaciuto al momento mi piace anche la
pagina di facebook e come ogni video
trovate nella descrizione se volete
potete seguire o vs sui social twitter
facebook e instagram è inoltre volevo
anche dirvi che se volesse nel caso fare
shopping sul sito vi lascio al sito in
descrizione questo per evitare di
ritrovarvi marco castagna c'è marco
campagna ma che vi chiama nei momenti
più bui della giornata se sì ti sei
decimi diavolo fosse vivo reja